hello folks and welcome to rational
science
uh i'm in south america and uh so i'm
improvising a lot of stuff here i hope
you can hear me well
see me well if not please let me know in
the comments section there
okay
uh anyways i'm gonna get started with
the first half which is usually
about extinction topics related to
extinction and then i'm going to
continue with the second part which is
the lecture on physics today we're going
to have
a little look at
energy what in the world is energy we
use this word every day do we know what
it is
okay so let's get started with the
important stuff here uh how much time we
have on the clock before uh
humans reach their dead end okay and
yeah please let me know if you can't
hear me or see me okay
okay so let's go with this i had a
bit of news
and it went like this a virtual meeting
that we had here with uh mr
biden and president of china
and it turns out that
they they were
on zoom
they were they were talking i guess this
is going to be the first time that uh
presidents talk through zoom
uh at high levels and they won't need to
travel anymore
well that's good i mean i think we're
going to be saving some money on uh
trips you know air force one will be
grounded
and they'll be uh talking through the
you know through the uh internet which
is good in a way you know if they can
resolve those issues
uh by talking directly why travel
you know and even though they say that
they missed
you know the
personal contact
uh
i think people will eventually get used
to seeing this kind of stuff
anyways they had very low expectations
for the meeting first of all
and they made no major announcements no
joint statement
the united states talked about the
uyghurs the hong kong
china says that's meddling in their
internal affairs stop them cold there
and uh and then they talked about you
know having a healthy competition
and just leaving their differences
in competition alone you know to compete
uh
fairly
according to
the american side they're not the
chinese they're not competing fairly
because uh i guess when they mention
these things they're saying in a way
that people are compelled to work more
or less like
uh
like they're slaves it's like slave
labor that sort of thing so they're
insinuating that and uh whenever the
united states can it will
punish china
for
economically right
for
doing things inside their country which
the united states considers against
democratic
and again it's just a question of you
know the chinese saying well you know
those are our affairs don't meddle in
our internal affairs and of course they
consider taiwan
an internal affair that the united
states has no business getting into
okay it's like if china got into
involved into something happening i
don't know in california or kansas or
new york
uh the united states would say uh that's
our business you know and so these are
the issues
and uh that's on the oriental side uh
way
in the east here we some here we have
something a little closer by and that's
um
russia
and apparently there's uh
there's already been a um
according to this uh
uh
headline here says that they've already
started the cold war again or the world
war three you could say
says war in space began on sunday here's
why the superpowers are on
red alert okay
and what are they talking about well
they're talking about uh you know
uh russia um having
tested
a um
a
killer satellite you know something that
kills satellite says is if a major
superpower were to erupt it will be in
space satellites will stop working
screens will go blank military
communications will break down
now imagine if that happened in the
world today no internet essentially
right
that would be quite a problem because
not only for
military issues
but also for economic issues can you
imagine the internet going down suddenly
you don't have access to your bank
account nobody knows how much money
anybody has
you know
it says the testing of a russian
anti-satellite weapon this weekend
caused a major stir with no prior
warning a russian space weapon was
launched traveled 300 miles above the
earth and successfully obliterated a
defunct soviet-era spy satellite uh the
mess it has created signaled that moscow
can shoot down satellites in low earth
orbit
if it's so desires
so uh we're in a new era where uh we
depend so heavily on the internet
uh especially military depend on it
economics depends on it and now we can
shoot those
satellites down
and i'm sure the united states
has that same capability if if it uh if
it's not developing it right and i'm
sure soon china will also
and so the question is you know if all
these countries now have a chance
or the opportunity the ability
to knock down the other guy's satellite
can there be a world war three
you know i mean
where is it going to stop when
these uh countries do not reach an
agreement on things like taiwan or
ukraine
are they going to knock each other
satellites
out is that what it's going to be and
once they knock them out you know that's
the end of communications
except for the flat earthers they
believe all this is done through sardine
cans you know that you can talk through
a can and that's connected through a
little wire to the other guy on the
other side you know
but for everybody else uh you know it's
gonna be a big problem
okay uh
phil says here
uh says propaganda fear porn for the
kool-aid drinking masses that are dumbed
down lied to fluoridated programmed like
a computer say
to stay lost and stuck in a matrix of
lies and deception and blah blah blah
blah blah and he goes on uh talking
about the government the church major
corporations media hollywood
um lots of people have this notion that
out there you know there are a group of
people who govern the world
and you know uh illuminati the new world
order people whatever you want to call
them it's a group of rich people out
there that allegedly or
apparently right uh govern the world and
have decision powers over millions of
people they can move things around
because they have the money the
influence the power uh they have the
connections okay
and so a lot of people today fear or
have this notion that uh
someone is in control out there like
moving pawns on a chess
board and they can do anything they want
and so a lot of people when i talk about
extinction they bring these issues up
like you know immediately they go into
this uh illuminati kind of thing they
say well you know it's it's the powers
that be that governing etcetera and
they're they're going to take over the
world they're going to corral all people
out there you know
keep them as slaves they have these
ideas
and all i can tell you is that no
when the world collapses when the global
economy collapses
these people will have no power
because what's going to collapse is the
money
so these people won't have any money no
way of influencing even their
their servants whoever works for them
now why would they work for for these
people if
what are they going to give them uh
money
you know if there is no money and money
is no more what are you going to pay
your you know your servants with
so they won't have uh hit men or
anything like that because they have no
way of controlling them in fact they
better fear their own hitmen because
their hitmen are probably gonna take you
know uh
vengeance maybe
against them saying who are you now
so
you know uh this notion that the powers
that be will corral people using the
army or whatever
you got to control the army the only way
you control the army is by paying them
you can't pay the army the army's got to
rebuild as well
so think about that okay what i'm saying
is money will collapse money will be no
more
and again please let me know if uh you
can't hear me or see me okay
uh
it's happened to me in the past where i
talk and there's nothing there
okay here's another comment thou says
contributors to this inflationary cycle
we talked about inflation the other day
the climate agenda of the government has
chilled new oil production with
excessive regulations in taxes inflating
gas and oil prices 25 percent of gas and
oil is used for plastics and fertilizers
he mentioned a couple more
cooling climate and crop losses
contributing to inflation of food prices
starvation will reduce world
population uh-huh uh i don't i'm not
sure about that one you know uh
starvation
uh
really today kills
a few people in some country in the
world and i'm being kind when i say a
few maybe a few thousand maybe even a
million um that could happen
but that's not gonna have an impact on
the global economy the global economy uh
will collapse only when you have
full-fledged starvation you know then
you have a problem but if one country a
very poor country you know has some
people starving out there in the in the
wild because they lived in the country
and they have nothing to eat
uh that's not gonna affect the world
economy so there's going to be no
decrease in population there's going to
be an increase in population until the
economy collapses once the economy
collapses oh yeah then you'll have a
very sharp
decrease in population because of what
because of starvation okay
so uh anyways that's my take on that
manipulated lockdown shutdown just in
time delivery of goods cheaper prices
for the consumer created shortages
unemployment due to manipulated
unemployment payments in other words you
know subsidies reducing production yeah
there's a lot of that going on today i
don't know if that we're going to come
out of that because one of the issues
that i mentioned the other day is that
there's like 10 million jobs in the
united states available and not enough
people to take them because apparently
people have something better to do with
their time than work for minimum wage
so maybe they live with their parents
they live with their wives whatever
and
and so and make maybe a little money on
the side and that's enough for them to
live without having to work
so keep that in mind you know that
work is now
not desirable as it used to be in the
old days okay especially at such low
wages if they double the you know the
money
the amount of money they're going to
give your salary you might decide to
work but you know with the way things
are right now
uh salaries are so depressed that a lot
of people decide not to work because
they find other ways of living
okay and it doesn't mean they're going
to be rich
or live you know
throwing butter up in the air but
they can live and they can just uh make
it to the end of the month some somehow
they're not gonna find a job they're not
gonna look for a job
and here the result will be stagflation
okay
there's an opinion for you uh yeah i
think uh
inflation's got to be a problem there
are many factors affecting inflation
like this fall says
uh but i think it's inflation that's
going to eat into the salaries and right
now the salaries are quite depressed i
mean real
in in real terms right and
inflation is going to eat into that if
the government doesn't somehow raise
minimum wages significantly
or
companies don't
raise their their workers salaries
significantly
there's gonna be a problem because
people a lot of people from the middle
class will be falling into the poor
class
and meaning that they can barely make it
to the end of the month
some maybe not make it to the end of the
month those people are going to go out
into the streets and break windows and
burn tires
okay then it's just um
that revolution
grassroots revolution kind of thing uh
french revolution russian revolution you
know that sort of thing uh that's very
likely to happen even in advanced
countries
uh people say no that that'll never
happen in germany they told me no that
that won't happen you know the
food lines the soup kitchens
uh get ready for them
okay uh regarding homosexuality that we
raised the topic the other day
phel says sex hormones start with a base
molecule of cholesterol
maybe replacing animal fats with
vegetable oils has contributed to the
homo expression okay
ironically saturated fat assists the
liver in breaking down toxins that also
may contribute to homo expression eat
your butter and make sure it is real
[Laughter]
okay what can i say
um
i'm gonna argue that it has nothing to
do with food
even though uh food in some way maybe
affects the sex
uh
i think sex is especially orientation
right uh is
150 percent uh
how you're born okay it's in your genes
okay and no one no one decides one day
says well i'm not gonna look at girls
anymore i think i'm gonna look at men it
doesn't work that way i don't think it
does uh i think you're born with that
orientation you can't do anything about
it okay whether it's nice or not that's
a separate issue but i'm saying that i
think these people are born that way i
don't think any
pers
no different heterosexual he's not gonna
come out one day and say well i think
i'm gonna like men now no it doesn't
happen you don't change your orientation
overnight because you were beaten or
because your your mother educated the
wrong way or your father hits you or
whatever i don't believe that
you're born with it period
okay another foul says homosexuality
might be a spin-off in the pursuit
against the path of least resistance
whoa what is this about
well there's success it's a successful
approach remains to be seen
for example homosexuals exposed to the
hiv who somehow acquired natural
immunity would now be favorable to those
species for their enhancement of genetic
diversity in other words he's saying
that
um if the guy survives that you know
he's gone through this um sifter
hiv in this case in this example and so
now he's got a different genetic code
that uh you know
i guess contributes to
humanity you know to the fact that we
have
uh
better resistance the next generation
has better resistance because this guy
survived that sort of thing were they
also able to survive other unique
diseases exposure in that lifestyle
okay hello just let me know if you can't
hear me or see me okay i'm worried about
that because again i'm in south america
and i'm improvising a lot of this stuff
i hope it comes out all right
anyways were they also able to survive
other unique diseases exposures in that
lifestyle and eventually have children
you could consider that spin-off to be
sustaining said life a bit longer yeah
again um
uh
you're preaching to the wrong guy here
i'm saying all
all this stuff has to do with evolution
and um
the fact that we've intermarried for so
long here let me show you a little
little picture that i made here just to
give you my peace of mind my 10 cent's
worth okay here it is
this is what happened as far as i'm
concerned we had you know for millions
of years we were evolving and then maybe
200 000 years ago you could say our
species began or came into being in the
sense that we could trace our lineage to
about 200 maybe 300 000 years ago and we
could still mate
with whoever lived in those days about
that time if you go farther back maybe
to 500
600 700 000 years ago we would not be
able to mate and have successful
children with anyone in those days so
that's what i call the beginning of the
human race anywhere between two hundred
thousand three hundred thousand years
ago okay since then we've been
inbreeding we've been breeding only with
our own kind we did not breed with the
denisovans we did not breed with
neanderthals or any other species on the
planet
essentially you know we
inbred and we've been doing that for
maybe 200 300 000 years and now we're
having genetic problems of all kinds
physical and mental and i think that
this homosexuality thing is the
uh
the mental one of the mental
variations that we have today thanks to
the fact that we've been in breeding for
200 000 years you know at some point
you're gonna have problems
and here let me present a little bit of
proof okay evidence for those people who
rely on proof and evidence okay here's
uh which is unscientific by the way it's
just part of religion it's just
convincing persuading okay that's what
i'm going to be doing now and here it is
uh you find the gay mennonites okay and
uh you go to the atlantic
magazine there and here's this article
from 2015 you'll find a lot others okay
out there says uh the the denomination
has gone through many schism uh they're
talking about the mennonites here which
is a branch that came out of the amish
and all these people who came in the
17th century to the united states right
often uh over issues of tradition
modernity
at one time it was buttons versus eye
hooks on blouses and whether women
should uh have to wear bonnets that was
in the old days but today more recently
it's been women's leadership in the
church you have some women who are
pastors
or leaders in the
mennonite church
unheard of unthought of you know
unimaginable
and acceptance of those who identify as
lb lgbtq xyz and so on yeah all these uh
problems are new
in that religion and so and they are
also in the homage here's the amish okay
let me give you a couple of
pieces of evidence here one is uh one
site that says the counseling center and
the guy tells uh has a blog on uh you
know on how he was
he became or he was born he says you
know
uh he i guess at the age of 14 he
realized he was homosexual okay so i
guess they kick them out they say look
you either marry a woman have 10
children like all amish have or you get
out of here and uh
another group formed this um
what is it the lgbta uh alma lgbt amish
okay
uh
a site for all those who are kicked out
of the amish
church or religion and uh they have
nowhere to go because they are
homosexual and so this is what that's
about so you got that lgbt with a horse
okay so so
these old religions they're having
problems why because they have the same
problems that we have like they call it
the english world the world outsider
frontiers
and they're having the same they're
experiencing the same type of problems
that we are in our
normal world you could say right
and uh why because they've been
inbreeding for the last 400 years maybe
so this gives you something to think
about um
they've been inbreeding in being today
they're having physical problems after
so many years of inbreeding
they're having a lot of mental problems
and
one of those aspects is homosexuality
okay so uh
you know you should
look at all these cases because i'm
saying that again it's got to do with
inbreeding the fact that you cannot
didn't breed
any species or at least many species i
can't say all species but many species
if they inbreed for thousands and
thousands and thousands of years at some
point they're going to have uh
physical and and or mental problems
and you see that there are lions who
are homosexual you see the male lion
mounting another male lion you can
interpret that any way you want and say
well this is this this is that yeah
whatever you want to say uh we see it on
sheep and sheep are a little different
than lions and nevertheless they both
are mammals and they both have
homosexuality about 10 of sheep are
homosexuals and like i said the other
day did they cross sections of the
brains of sheep and they found that yeah
the homosexuals ones have different
brains than the heterosexual ones
so you figure out
okay so uh let's move on to um
subject of today which is energy
and i'm going to start with where i left
off the other day which was uh weight
work
and uh then we move on to energy and
appella raised an issue and he says the
following says uh so and so encore
explains that the moon doesn't weigh
anything because it is in free fall
i was saying that you do not need
contact you do not need to put the ball
or the box or whatever you put
the pyramid on
on a scale
make contact with a scale
in order to have weight in order to say
oh
now
the sphere the box has weight
no no the weight the box had weight even
before you put it on the scale
but this valve believes that you need
contact that there has to be surface to
surface contact in order for there to be
weight there has to be this pressure
between two surfaces
okay and i'm saying no you don't
and uh let's let's show why he's
mistaken okay
and here you see uh where all this comes
from it comes from uh mr einstein okay
and mr einstein in 1907 you know the
time he was developing special
relativity
he came up with this notion that a
person falling like in an elevator
is uh someone cut the ropes and and the
guy's just falling or falling from an
airplane
for him it's like if being in space he
doesn't feel his weight okay so we have
this notion today objects in free fall
do not experience being accelerated
downwards okay like for example to
toward the earth or other massive body
but rather weightlessness and no
acceleration
okay
but we have a problem because weight
is a gravitational phenomena it's
defined that way
weight is equal force acting on the
object due to gravity
so do i need a scale to press upon in
order to have gravity
or is there gravity or does every object
in the universe have gravity
you know here let me show you okay
here's a
pictorial way of looking at this okay
and you can see that everything is
interconnected in the universe the
electric universe calls them filaments
okay and what you see is that all
galaxies stars and everything is really
connected
they're connected in some way okay
physically connected out there and
everything has gravity with respect to
everything else
okay so this notion that uh
that you need contact is wrong you had
weight before you fell to earth okay
that's that's my take on this i'm saying
that
everything has weight
you don't know the value because that
doesn't matter
what matters is the definition
of the word weight which is a
gravitational phenomenon and everything
in the universe which is an object thing
okay usually a
celestial object of some kind
is gravitationally attracted to
everything else because everything is
physically connected
okay everything is interconnected
everything in the universe all matter is
interconnected
uh also shows uh that mox principle you
know that when you turtle around looks
like you know being pulled by the stars
yeah correct that's what you're pulling
out against in a way okay
so everything is connected you don't
need to weigh yourself in order to have
weight because weight is not defined as
a contact force weight is defined as a
gravitational
influence of some kind okay and i'm
saying that you have weight
when you fall to earth but what einstein
was talking about and again it shows the
mentality of the mathematicians
he was talking about feeling what you
feel
we don't care what you feel there are no
observers in science there are no
observers
in physics in physics you have weight
whether you observed or not the moon has
weight whether you whether it touches
something or not the moon has weight
because it's attracted by the earth
somehow
we say all the atoms there are connected
physically connected to the earth and
the earth swings the moon around you
know and my little
this this is what's happening okay my
hand is going to be the earth and this
is what's happening
why because the moon
is every out here i have only one string
but every atom on the in the moon is
connected to every atom of the earth
that's why the the earth swings the moon
around space is nothing so it has no
nothing the moon has nothing to scrape
its shoulder against you know there's no
friction that's why the moon just rolls
around around around and the earth rolls
around the earth the sun for the same
reason every atom on the earth is
connected to every atom
that makes up the sun and the sun swings
the earth around and the moon and the
rest of the planets
uh without any friction
that's what's happening and yeah that we
call that gravity because otherwise the
earth would fly away
and yes there is gravity and the earth
has weight
and it's called weight
okay not mass
okay
uh mass is the quantity of matter we
don't count the quantity of matter of
the earth or of the moon we say it's got
it weighs so much and you give the
value in kilograms okay and or pounds or
whatever
and that's weight and you say well yeah
because we use mass and weight and mass
and weight yeah this is the problem
there is no difference between mass and
wayne but these people want to give you
the idea that there is a difference
there ain't no difference mass and
weight are the same thing because they
never have been
determined in any other way other than
through wayne through contact weighing
which is what this fellow is talking
about but that's not what it is in
physics in physics we care about the
mechanism and the mechanism again
everything is connected
therefore everything has gravity which
is a falling of something towards
another where the ropes fan out and the
reason the earth doesn't fall to the sun
and or the moon towards the earth is
because it's being swung around so you
have centripetal motion and you have
centrifugal motion they cancel each
other out this guy rolls and rolls
around and there's nothing to stop it
because there's no friction with space
because space is nothing nothing is that
which doesn't have shape
that's way it works now we can talk
intelligently about these things okay
okay here's what energy looks like okay
we're going to talk about energy i want
you to right up front i'm going to tell
you what it looks like this is energy
you've seen it here okay for the first
time here it is that's energy
okay
so if you ever want to know what energy
looks like there it is
okay we have energy
okay so i guess the uh lecture is over
there you see it
we wanted to show you what energy is
there you see it
nothing more to say right
okay but uh there's a little bit of a
problem um
here we have a fellow and he says the
following he says
energy is an object
okay that's what i showed something
there was something there whatever it
was
there was contrast there was shape it
was moving okay i showed it to you in
motion but
there's something there there's contrast
something in motion
that's a something right even though
it's
in motion it has to be a something to be
in motion okay and i showed you
something so smoke some spirit some
whatever you want to call it that was
that was energy
okay and he says it is the deltas
between frame what is a delta
delta's not a physical object delta's a
letter that's what it is delta could be
a difference i don't know what delta is
okay but then he says energy is the
capacity for work
well if energy's the capacity it's not
an object
but see these people just use these
words without ever defining them they
don't define the word object so they can
say yeah energy is an object energy is a
energy is b and energy is c as long as
he doesn't define a b or c
you can say whatever he's got to start
by defining object
and if object has shape you can't say
that capacity has shape
because if energy is a capacity it can't
be an object if it's an object can't be
a capacity that's how simple it is but
then he says not any matter chance uh or
work itself
so uh yeah if it's not matter
then what is its concept
okay so yeah you can't talk about
transferring of
concepts okay so here you have a
a guy a little smarter than this guy
his name was richard feynman and she's
it is important to realize that in
physics today we have no knowledge of
what
energy is
what feynman didn't realize was that
energy is not a what
what is what we call a shape
in other words a what is a thing a
substance
uh an entity uh
something
object whatever those words you want to
use okay it's that which has shape
that's what a what is so you can't say
what is energy because it's an
irrational question
energy is not a what energy is a concept
concepts are the opposite of objects not
really
opposite but they're in a different
category okay it's either an object or a
concept either you have shape or you
don't have shape if you don't have shape
you're a concept that's how simple it is
so every word in the dictionary falls
under one of those two categories either
object has shape or concept doesn't have
shape in fact the word concept is really
a relationship between two objects
that's that's what we invented all
concepts
okay so god has to choose whether he's
an object or a concept
if he wants to be an object be the guy
who makes waves the magic wand and makes
things appear fine he's an object
but god cannot also be intelligence and
love and all these other concepts
okay
okay um
and here's the punch line on that uh
yeah you can't
energies not a what energy is a concept
okay in fact the fact that you define
something like energy in other words
this word
uh if it's defined it's a concept
because objects we don't define we can't
define an object you can't define the
word table
okay you point to a table then you
describe it
but first you have to point that's how
we designate
objects in physics in science and you
can't point to energy what are you going
to point to that smoke that i showed you
a little bit ago
okay so energy again is the capacity the
ability those are concepts there's no
physical standalone object called the
capacity
okay so you can't transfer the capacity
what are you gonna transfer okay so
concepts have no shape or location and
therefore do not move you cannot move
love because love is not a physical
object that i can show you you got to
have love would have to have shape
and then i could move it around kick it
or whatever i could show you love in
motion i can't do that because you know
it's not a physical object and so people
introduce these uh words of ordinary
speech
and they say
look uh
love i can transfer love i can transfer
energy
no no before you can talk about
transferring something you have to show
the picture of the thing that you're
gonna transfer for the purposes of
physics then you can say look i'm gonna
show you how the ball
is transferred from a to b i could do
that with a ball you know i can do that
with this okay here i can say here's
that a and here's that b that i can do
how do you do that with a concept what
are you going to move what are you going
to see
okay so this is where the problem is
these people never define the terms
especially the word object which is the
one that kills all religions okay
concepts cannot be transferred from a to
b and there you have energy just a word
that's being transferred is that what it
is okay so so no you um you know you
can't you can't introduce
terms of ordinary speech or um
notions of ordinary speech into physics
and physics is literal
and in order for it to be literal you
have to have the object you have to have
the ball you have to have the let the
square the cube okay you need to have
something then you can talk about motion
because what can the only thing that can
move is an object a thing okay you can't
say that you're going to transfer energy
transfer love transfer intelligence
transfer grace
you can't transfer concepts
but this is how these people talk and
that's what they have in their tiny
minds so they talk that way okay they're
religious people in the end
i call them spiritualists because they
move concepts around in the old days
they moved spirits
and why because they couldn't see all
these mechanisms that mother nature has
all these mediators that are invisible
and intangible so they invented this
spirit
and it's these people who have taken
over mathematics and teach
so-called mathematical physics to the
new generations and they learn the same
words but they they're
the words are now different they're
called energy they're called
weight they're called uh
um
vortex ether
field and energy and mass you know they
have all these terms that they move
around and all those are concepts
you can't move concepts around first you
have to have an object in order to con
conceptualize motion what is motion
two or more locations of what an object
it has to be an object what is an object
shape you have to have it's that which
has shape then you can be rational you
can talk sensibly you cannot introduce
concepts as objects in physics
okay and uh so uh the other day we
covered work okay and it turns out it's
associated with this word famous word
called energy okay
anything that is capable of performing
work possesses energy
possesses energy
you mean possessed like i possess two
coins in my pocket is that how it
possesses energy is energy a thing that
you can put in your
pocket hold in your hand throw away is
that what energy is some something like
that
energy represents potential work
okay
so there's this mysterious whatever
we're going to call it energy x z
whatever you want to call it and now
what we're going to be doing is
doing work with that
what was work well we talked about that
the other day work is what force
applied over a distance traveled
and if you just have that then you're
moving something horizontally which you
see at the bottom
and that's if the full equation is with
times cosine of a if a is one then you
have to horizontal uh work
but
uh if you move it
up and down then the question is whether
you can use this equation or you have to
use the gravitational equation because
you're push pulling the box against
gravity or dropping it towards gravity
whichever doesn't really matter but
you're going vertically
with respect to an axis that goes
through the center of the earth
so you're talking about up and down
and you're going to be talking about
gravity pulling or pushing against
gravity now you have to use the
gravitational equation and then it gets
more complicated when you get on any
inclined plane because now you have the
two components the horizontal and the
vertical component
and again the way the mathematicians
figured it out they said we're going to
just use cosines
which is you know a
trigonometric uh
accounting system that's all it is
but we're not learning with that what is
physically occurring
see if
if gravity is in is involved in this
situation then you have to factor what
the fact that no matter whether you use
horizontally or up and down or inclined
in an inclined plane what you have is
every rope
from every atom that forms the object
that you're moving in any direction is
tied to every atom on earth you have to
factor that in and that's physics
because now you can see what's happening
physically
you can't do that with if you put cosine
of a
cosine of is just an accounting
procedure
for describing it doesn't give you any
insight into how gravity works or what
work really is okay
but again anything that is capable
performing work is what they call energy
okay so now we have we're
approximating a definition you could say
okay or at least the notion of what
energy is
but here's a clarification a man
standing with a box on his shoulder
right
like this
okay is not doing any mechanical work if
you're just holding the box there okay
you're not doing any mechanical work
then nothing is in motion you're just
standing there with a box there okay
and even though the test tires him you
know if you have a big box you're gonna
get tired right but you haven't done any
mechanical work the box could be
supported equally well by the floor with
no expenditure of energy so i could put
that same box on the floor
there's no expenditure of energy but we
still seem to have
some expenditure of energy in there
because it's called well not expenditure
but we have some energy that is stored
and they call that potential energy okay
a situation which does not require the
expenditure of energy can't be regarded
as work
so we don't have work but we have energy
okay so we got to find out what this
energy mysterious
thing called energy is okay let's find
out let's see we can get to the bottom
of it
okay so here we have um a couple of
people who addressed it remember in the
19th century
it was the age of manufacturing
and it had the steam
engines built uh they built trains all
these cabooses they had um
cars
eventually beginning of the 20th century
they came up with the um
with uh airplanes and so you know they
were developing engines so they were
very concerned about this mysterious
thing called energy so energy was
uh studied whatever that was you know it
was studied
in great deal by a lot of researchers
and they were trying to get to the
bottom of it but what were they trying
to do they were trying to do math
that's where the problem is they were
doing mathematics not physics
you know they were doing experiments out
there and then uh
measuring and then coming up with
equations well that gave them a
description it did not give them an
insight into what was causing
this thing and they call that unknown
energy and so the the word energy
entered the lexicon very strongly in the
19th century was there before then right
but
today we everybody talks about energy
because it's the the word that you can
fit in anywhere you want
you know it's the wild card so to speak
you know the joker in the uh rummy game
you can put it use it as any card you
want you just say energy and you're done
and nobody's going to question it
because nobody knows what energy is
why because it hasn't been defined and
second no one knows if it's an object or
a concept you know there's all these
problems and everybody says well we
don't care that's a semantics
that's not physics physics is doing an
experiment and measuring and giving you
an equation that's fizzy
well we beg to differ okay no
and so here we have one follow and uh
this was julius meyer german guy and he
came up with his first law of
thermodynamics
i guess his thermos was
rolling he said oh thermodynamics you
know
thermos dynamics
uh and so what did he
they came up with this equation it says
change in the internal energy is equal
to energy attitude to heating and minus
energy loss due to work that's in
general terms what this first law of
thermodynamics
stands for okay and what does it mean in
in
you could say in physical terms because
this is not even physical
again it's just a description so the
total energy of an isolated system is
constant
it's got to be um it's got to be a
closed system okay
and energy can be transformed from one
form to another for example potential or
chemical
energy to kinetic energy
but what are they talking about they're
talking about accounting
all they're saying is we take
energy over here and we turn it into a
different type of energy over here
but what do we mean by that are we
turning smoke into a solid rock is is
that what energy is
and no the issue is that it's just an
accounting procedure it's saying look
this part of the equation turns into
that part of the equation because we go
from potential to kinetic energy just a
different type of uh aspect of this
unknown called energy undefined word
called energy
the spirit turns from black to white but
we don't know what the spirit is so to
speak that's more or less the situation
but can be neither created nor destroyed
yeah you can't destroy a concept you
know we tried to destroy concepts and
it's very hard
you know you can't destroy distance you
can't destroy
what
thought
you can't break the guy's head then you
can destroy thought but you can't
destroy concepts
you can destroy a chair
you can destroy a tree a rock a dog you
know things you're gonna do you can
destroy your house
but you can't destroy a concept what do
you mean destroy a concept how do you
rip it i mean physically we're talking
about physics here right we're not
talking about math can you rip a concept
and you rip love
can you rip grace can you rip
intelligence you know can you
pound it and say i'm gonna hit
intelligence you can hit the head
which kills the processes we call
intelligence but can you get
intelligence out here and bang it and
break it into pieces
so yeah you can't create nor destroy
energy because
you know it's it's nonsense to talk like
this
because energy is a concept
and yes it makes no sense to say that
you can you know create or destroy
energy but it didn't stop there here you
had uh another fellow he came a few
years later also german his name is
rudolph clausius and he came up with the
second law or started the second law of
thermodynamics and again here you have
the change in entropy
my god what is entropy change in entropy
is what equals the change in the heat
transfer of within the system right uh
divided by the environmental temperature
that you have out there
okay so uh you can see that all these
people working on equations why because
they were interested in technology
that's what they were working on they
were doing experiments to understand
this mysterious thing we call energy and
how it works and so they develop
equations what are equations
descriptions that's all they are we have
no explanation so far first law second
law whatever those laws are
we have no explanation of anything all
we have is a mathematical description
that's what these two so-called laws are
and that's what the mathematicians call
them they call them laws
uh because it's a pattern it's a
repeatable pattern that they can measure
repeatably and they call that science
because you can measure the table
repeatably so you measure the table one
meter the other guy comes over saying i
measured it a little better one
meter one millimeter
aha and the other guy said no no you're
wrong too it's one meter one millimeter
and one micrometer that i was able to
measure and so now you measured more
accurately and the other guy comes with
a ruler he confirms that i say oh
repeatable reading the other guy comes
in and says i repeated it too so it's
one meter
one millimeter and one micrometer all
that's how much the table measures
and they call it a law the law of the
table
is that what science is just measuring
and
giving you an equation giving you a
bunch of numbers and units
and calling them laws the laws of god i
guess and i don't know
is that what science is about or is
science explaining how mother nature
runs this universe
that's what we want to know
understand
okay so here we go um
uh the the
how energy is used this again remember
this 19th century okay primarily this is
when a lot of the stuff all the engines
were being developed okay the criterium
by which energy is recognized as such is
its ability to be transformed into
work
okay you got to turn that into work
otherwise it's useless but what are we
talking about this is this is technology
what does this have to do with
understanding how the universe works
which is physics
this has to do with just describing
uh
a mechanical
uh
thing that works there like a car works
how much energy you need how much gas
you need they call that energy as well
you know so you need so much gas and it
lasts so long if you run the motor at so
much speed et cetera et cetera et cetera
that's all technology we still don't
know uh what this energy
spirit is that's the issue
to use energy and say oh you put energy
in your tank well no i put gas in my
tank
okay so what is this energy that's being
transformed are we transforming the gas
into what into motion is that what it is
you know again uh
it's easy to use this word energy
whenever you can't fill in the blanks
and that's what these people do
says anybody in motion possesses energy
okay what is energy i mean i possess it
great
sometimes i don't have energy
but i guess i possess energy whatever it
is i need to know what that energy is
before you know before i can use the
word possess
you know is it the same thing as
possessing a dime in my pocket is that
how you possess energy
can we use that language in physics what
these people are using here
the energy of a moving body is called
what kinetic energy kinetic referring to
motion okay but that's not the only type
there's another one uh
there are more kinds but these are the
main ones potential energy an elevated
body can also do work it can acquire
increasing speed
that is you know kinetic energy when
falling the energy of an elevated
elevated body is called potential energy
okay so we have
kinetic energy which is energy of motion
and we have potential energy static
energy ready to be used for something
and again all this has to do with
technology it has nothing at all to do
with how to how the universe works okay
because you can't explain how the
universe works using the word energy
energy is a word of religion because
first it's undefined then people say
they don't know what it is then they
don't know if it's a what meaning a
thing or a concept
but they use it anyways and anyone who
attacks their
sacred word is you know heretic
and um
and uh you know you're trying to kill
their religion and they say oh you're
doing semantics you're just doing some
man that's not physics that's the way
they handle it because they have no
answers because they had they have no
idea like uh find one said there they
have no idea what energy is and if ein
feinstein who had a nobel prize could
not tell the difference between an
object and a concept
what can you expect with all these bozos
that you know that just
dabbled a little bit in so-called
physics
they get into the mathematical physics
you wonder why they don't just go to
church and pray
because these are all religious people
anyone using the word energy is a
religious fanatic that's all he is he's
trying to
stay
he wants to keep that word energy
because without it his entire religion
is lost
so energy is an extremely important word
for them you can't attack it because
you're you're attacking their god you're
raping their virgin okay this is the
issue
okay so uh here we have um
a little uh
gift that shows that you can change one
type of energy into another you have
potential energy at the top
and as you drop the ball it loses
kinetic potential energy and you convert
that into kinetic energy
so
what transformation happened here i mean
can you please tell me what changed into
what
did a
dog turn into a cat is that what they're
saying is this what we're talking about
says when an object falls it loses
potential energy and gains kinetic
energy gains you know you acquire
okay
and the increase in kinetic energy is
exactly compensated by the decrease in
potential energy
what did we learn
this is an accounting procedure this is
you know you have your your bank account
and you take money out of
your assets and put it in the debit
and so you you change your money from
one type to another from plus blue to
red negative
is this what this is potential to
kinetic energy
what has changed here what understanding
can you get from potential being changed
into
kinetic or chemical to kinetic or
whatever
what what understanding do we have
i mean this yeah
the equation you can even memorize and
write the equation and pass the test
you know say well you have so much
potential energy change the kinetic
energy and here's the equation that
shows the transformation
those are all descriptions just uh you
know jewels turned into a different type
of jewels maybe
what is that that's nothing we still
have no idea what energy is it is it a
cloud like i showed earlier uh some kind
of smoke that's out there is it a spirit
what are we talking about
what hashem has the form of the energy
changed
again did the dog turn into a cat did
this smoke turn into a different type of
smoke did it change its color
this is the issue the issue is that this
is not physics saying using the word
energy or saying that you change one
engine energy into another type of
energy you're not explaining
the mechanism what what's happened
what's changed
all you're doing is describing something
not explaining
what's going on in in that invisible
world
and the only way you're gonna explain it
is making that energy visible and
finding out what it really is if it is a
what
if it is a one you have something
physical then you can say this change
into that change its form
or it changed its structure it became it
went from
solid to liquid or something like that
and you can show what happened
and not describe it mathematically but
show exactly what changed
and then for that you don't need
the word energy all you say the dog
turned into a cat
then we all understand it's very simple
you say the the tree turned into a house
we can all understand that because we
see the tree here
there was some manufacturing going on it
turned into a house you see the dog here
there's some voodoo magic whatever and
you turn it into a cat great we all
understand that but to say that
uh potential energy turned into uh
kinetic energy
that's just an accounting procedure
that's your money from the assets to the
to the uh liabilities that's all it is
okay uh and since all these people did
math uh
einstein did stay behind you know and he
came up with this apparently he's
credited with it i have my doubts that
he was the originator of this equation
because they were already dealing with
this kind of equation before then uh
whether he was the one that really came
up with it
i think you could say that it was a like
a group thing where several people
already had these notions maybe he was
the first one to formalize it and in
that sense yeah he probably gets the
credit but anyways uh it says e equals
mz squared great
equation everybody just repeats it
nobody understands what it means but uh
i mean in real term physical terms but
everybody knows how to say that oh equal
will seem mc squared and they say that's
einstein they all know that and that's
einstein's equation okay but we have a
problem we don't know if it's mass or
weight
and you say bill it's mass see it's the
little m it says mass
well yeah but you know uh we have this
energy and special relativity where if
the thing travels near the speed of
light it gains mass
well did it gain quantity of matter
which is the notion we have of mass or
is it pressing harder and harder against
the scale meaning it's weight
right
so maybe it's weight times velocity of
light square maybe that's what they're
talking about
okay or is there a difference between
mass and weight
and then uh velocity of light or speed
of light is that little c velocity or
speed what's the difference velocity has
direction speed only has magnitude
it's a scalar
and uh so those are the first things you
got to clarify then you got to clarify
the other thing is you know can a photon
move in circles one photon
okay can it move in circles
uh i don't know how you would draw the
uh
wave
you got a pinpoint wave and it's moving
around maybe a wave packet i guess i
don't know chop it off
at the ends you have this little wavy
thing and it moves around in circles can
can one photon move around in circles
around nothing or even around something
i don't care can it move in circles
okay so these are things you have to
look at because if it moves in circles
you're changing the direction
and like we held
in a couple
lectures ago
if you change the direction you're
changing the uh speed but they're saying
oh no we don't change the speed we're
changing the direction
okay but we have a problem with that
because if you change direction
you know you have the centripetal force
in the centrifugal force
they're casting out and that's why this
thing is going around in circles
so you have an acceleration which is
known as centripetal force
that's known that's an acceleration and
what they do is instead of talking about
the centrifugal centripetal force that's
pulling that's tugging against the
centrifugal
motion you know
or force caused by the motion of
something going around
it's being canceled but it's still being
pulled
okay it's a again it's uh it's this okay
that's what it is you swing it around
okay
and you have both centripetal
acceleration going in there is an
acceleration whenever something moves in
circles
and so does light accelerate and just
change directions
is is light being pulled from some
center like if it went around the sun
can a photon travel in circles
so yeah we have all these issues but
again uh all the equations that's all
they have e equals mz squared grade
every he gets a noble he says for that
you know i mean he didn't get it for
that he got it for the photoelectric
effect but yeah they could have given
him a noble for e equals mz squared what
is that that's a description what have
we learned
what have we learned
about how the universe works that's what
i'm talking about what have we learned
about you know what gravity is what have
we learned about what uh
you know
light is or what magnetism is
those are the things people want to
understand
and you know you're not going to get
them through equations
okay so here are my conclusions
for today conclusions energy is not a
thing
there's no thing no
cop no um
object no
um
entity called
energy no standalone thing that i can
bring to you like this i bring this this
ball to you and say this is a ball i
can't do that with energy say look this
is energy
this is a field this is a wave
transfers wave right uh this is a field
this two fields make a wave you know
uh this is time i can't bring time and
say look this is time i'll show it to
you
no because for that it would have to
have shape then you would say then you
can present it like that but you can't
do that with energy so energy is not a
thing because you cannot present it like
that
therefore you can't use it in physics as
a physical object
and therefore you can actually say that
you're going to transfer
energy because you can only in physics
it's literal i can transfer the ball
from a to b here it is i transferred the
ball that's called transferring the ball
i can't do that with energy i can't say
i transferred the energy what have i
transferred i haven't seen it please
make it visible you need to make it
visible for that energy would have to
have shape
okay and energy does not have shape so
you can't use it for mechanisms what is
a mechanism
mechanism what we do in physics we do a
physical interpretation
that's what physics is about you need to
give a physical interpretation of how
something happened
okay and you can't use it for you can't
do that with energy because you would
have to show it first first step is you
got to show energy
point to it
and then you can say okay now i'm going
to do this with that thing i called
energy then you can do that
but first you got to point to it for
that you have to it has to have shape
you should be able to draw it if you
can't draw energy you can't use the word
not as an object not in physics okay
energy it turns out that even as a
concept it's undefined there is no
definition of the word energy
we have no definition of the word energy
today okay because they have like 17
different types of energies and
they have potential energy chemical
energy and kinetic energy and who knows
what else they have all these energies
out there okay and what are they they're
just equations it's uh just like e
equals m c squared that's it that's
energy
the definition is what's on the other
side of the equal sign mass times
velocity of light squared or maybe it's
weight times
uh speed of light
squared who knows you know
and then again that squared gives you an
idea it's just an equation it's not
that's not a definition
okay that's just an equation that's a
description that they're going to use in
mathematics okay we don't have a
definition written out
because whatever you write out is wrong
they have 10 different types and they
use all 10 simultaneously
and then energy is a mathematical
concept
so what is it it's a spirit it's the
same word as spirit in the old
traditional religions no different than
the word spirit it's religious people
who have taken over
so-called physics it's known as
mathematical physics also known as
science
that's the people who run it are
religious people there are people who
memorize
pass their tests at the university get
their phds and then they just blab the
same thing over and over to the next
generation we've been doing that for 400
years now
and
essentially energy is a wild card
whenever you're ignorant whenever you
don't know anything you say energy and
people say ah he's so intelligent he
used the word energy okay that's what it
is a joker in a rummy game
that's what energy is
okay let's go with uh some of the
questions people had or comments that
people made this week
and we have a first foul he says
says uh you said before the universe
never had a beginning what about entropy
then
yeah what about it i mean
i don't know what this guy what's your
question
i mean he said what about entering yeah
what about it i mean you know what does
entropy have to do with the beginning of
the universe
we're talking about you know the
creation of matter from absolutely
nothing and it's not even that because
uh big bang created nothing as well
created something in nothing that's the
official version it created space and
matter
so it created nothing in something what
was there before then
you can't say nothing because that was
created at the big bang
so again a big bang is an irrational
theory it's a creationist theory
the traditional religions at least have
a better explanation they said god made
it you know moved his magic wand and
said abracadabra
and big bang started that we could all
understand what we won't understand is
who made god
and they say well he's eternal they have
different answers to that okay fine uh
we can live with that a little better
than you know the creation of matter and
nothing space and things from absolutely
nothing which is wrong anyways because
nothing was created at the big bang so
this is an irrational theory and of
course they say we don't know what
happened before the big bang of course
you don't
you know because that's what you got to
answer if you can't answer that question
your theory is nonsense it's idiocy
you know big bang
creationism
is is idiocy
the traditional religions are a step
ahead at least because they see god made
everything okay made nothing in
something okay he had his magic wand
where did god come from he's eternal
okay so they stop you there but at least
they have an answer for that what are
you gonna say for big bang that the
singularity was eternal
and what is the singularity if not
nothing which is what came out of the
singularity
so no uh big bang is an irrational
theory because they cannot tell you what
came before they can't tell you they
can't show you the first frame in the
movie or
you might say well the first frame was
the big bang the explosion okay fine i
want to know the minus one
frame
the one that came before the zero frame
that's the one that they need to they
can't explain that they don't have a
theory they have an irrational
explanation for how the unit for
how this universe works in this case uh
that it's expanding and so on okay they
can't use that because they cannot tell
you what came before the big bang that's
the question they have to answer they
can't answer that question their theory
is garbage
so all this stuff that the
mathematicians believe in that they say
oh big bang and that's when everything
started we know that for sure because
everything's expanding and we take the
movie backward and we end up with the
singularity all that's garbage all of it
150 of it
if they cannot tell you how
the first bit of matter came into being
the mechanism that's what we want to
understand not the mathematics of it not
how much time we don't care about that
we run another mechanism of how
something popped in from the void from
nothing and how nothing popped in from
the void from nothing because uh big
bang created both nothing in something
okay so we can't imagine uh what they're
talking about that's the issue
okay here's another fellow he raises
others she said bill gate has no idea
why the ropes don't get nodded
together unless we grant him the
assumption of magic ropes that just
happen to never knock together or cross
each other or whatever this is
irrational
i'll use your definition of touch when
two objects become one object well at
least as well learn something you know
at least he learned that um
what the definition of touch is
he's learning something at least
as far as
you know why the ropes don't get knotted
uh
we have an explanation for one at least
one situation there are several
situations okay let's go with one of
them here's one
okay i showed this in the past this is
the construction of the atom and how one
atom approaches another
by going through the rope itself because
remember the rope makes up the atom
okay
the rope uh one thread goes through the
center and the other thread goes around
and they come out the other end or in
some direction and they come out as a
rope okay so it's not coming out it's
just that the atom is made of the same
threads as the rope
there's a single thread in the entire
universe that makes up everything that's
the assumption okay so here's one
uh atom approaching another because it's
made of the same threads that the rope
is made of okay here it is okay so you
see one atom is just approaching another
one
like a bead sliding along the um uh
the abacus okay so the bead that goes
through the wire of an abacus
uh it doesn't um push on the
wire itself it doesn't collide against
it it just slides through it in this
case more and that's a good analogy for
what's happening here more or less uh
you see that the one thread goes around
the atom the other one goes through okay
to the center
and so the atom is eating into the rope
as it approaches another atom so in this
case there is no no
the reason the atom doesn't cross that
rope
is because it's sliding along the rope
okay so there it needs did not cross it
okay so that's and here's another
version of that okay here we have
fingers of a hand
and again that's
every atom in that
hand i've just showed a few there and
you got to think of them as hydrogen
atoms the simplest atoms and they're
sliding along a single rope
that's connecting that obviously there
are gazillions of ropes okay when that
man approaches the ball but my point
here is
if you have only a single atom sliding
along a single rope that's what's
happening the hand does not have to
cross does not have to cut the ropes
okay the ropes slide the hand slides
along the ropes the atoms are sliding
through the ropes okay
so there's no cutting across that's
that's the point that i'm trying to make
uh so this is one situation okay
and then what's the other issue well the
other issue is this fellow is asking the
wrong question okay and so let me let me
remove this for a second here
give me a second here
so what's happening the first the first
problem is this fellow has to answer
okay what do you propose instead if he
proposes particles
do particles occupy the same space do
particles go through
another particle
okay so this is the first question he's
got to answer
because if he's going to propose the
same thing then he's got nothing new to
add okay that's the first issue the
second issue is that
in the in
rational science
under the rope model okay
um
we define an object as that which has
shape not as that which you can touch or
see
so we don't have to answer the question
of a touch or c or crossing two ropes
crossing each other why because
touch is not an issue and c is not an
issue these people have touch and seeing
their brains because that's what they
were brainwashed to believe
that everything is touch and see that an
object is that which you can touch and
see so he's got to start bees
before you've been asked the question
he's got to tell us what an object is
what a thing is
and if a thing is that which does that
has shape
then touch and see the don't enter the
picture at all he shouldn't ask any
question related to touch your seat
now he says well how is it that ropes go
through each other
okay but the issue here is that
atoms don't go through each other like
they do in quantum in quantum everything
is possible a particle can be at two
places at once two
photons the two i'm sorry two atoms can
be at the same place at the same time
they can have two different uh states as
they called it
so they they have all these miracles out
there that
two two atoms can be in one position at
the same time
and uh in what we do in uh
rational science in uh the under the
rope model we say atoms cannot be at the
same place at the same time atoms have
surfaces and they bang against each
other
now ropes they are much thinner you're
talking about something unimaginably
thin unimaginably small
and they don't have the properties of
touch and see
but specifically in this case of touch c
is not an issue here i think
they don't have the property of touch if
they don't have the property of touch
it's irrational to say to say how do
they touch each other
no they don't have the property of touch
and if they don't have the property of
touch you know they don't have the
problem they don't have a problem going
right through each other because there
is no touch in that world in that
vanishingly thin world of the rope okay
this is the model of the rope
but this is made out of atoms this one
so this is just a model as far as the
shape of what we're talking about that's
why we call it a rope that's about the
only
uh property that uh the rope in the uh
invisible world of mother nature's have
the electromagnetic road it only has
that property the the shape of it other
than that it doesn't have the property
of touch i mean can this road go through
each other
this piece of road go through that one
no of course not because it's made out
of atoms and under the rope model you
know atoms can't go through atoms
in in the religion of quantum mechanics
they can
two atoms cannot get by the same space
under so
in under the quantum model you should be
able to have this rope go through that
rope that this piece of rope goes
through that piece of rope
because
they say that yeah that can happen in
the religion of quantum in science no it
can't you can't have this rope goes
through that piece of rope but that's uh
when we're talking about macro world
this type of rope when you're talking
about the microworld when you're talking
about the electromagnetic rope
uh it doesn't have the ability to touch
so what's the question the question is
why don't they touch each other why
don't they go why do they go through
each other again it's not an issue it's
not an issue because they don't have the
property of touch that's not what an
object is an object's that which has
shape not that which you can touch or
which can touch something else
so it's the touch issue that's got these
people crazy they're they're thinking
about touch
and yeah that gets them because they say
how can how can it possibly be that
mother nature works with these things
that you can't see or touch well we
can't see the air i mean why don't you
ask that question why can't we see the
air
yeah
yeah i don't know uh that's the way god
made our universe right mother nature
the devil someone made the universe that
way that we can't see the air i'm sorry
and so uh
go complain there you know raise a
complaint against mother nature okay
here's another following he says
energy is change over time
you still don't understand energy okay
yes work is a concept okay
uh yeah he got one right
how do we transfer change okay if
because if energy is change right how do
we transfer this thing they call energy
how do we transfer change
and
i like the answer he gives according to
you we killed the observer so that is a
bad question
yeah
observer has nothing to do with change
we can have change
without having any observer the moon you
know even before any humans or any life
was on earth the moon was already
changing moving from one place to
another there was change at least in
location
certainly in form
and so we can we can have change it
needs no observer
so uh this poor fellow thinks that you
need an observer for change i don't know
where he got that but again these are
religious people these are uh people who
were
brainwashed to use this word energy
to exhaustion and they can't get away
from it
if you destroy the word
energy for them you destroy their life
you just literally destroy their life
because they've been brainwashed to
exhaustion to talk about energy and they
use the word energy for everything and
they think they're being rational
and all they're doing is introducing
words of ordinary speech like energy
time
field
mass
and introduce this into physics as if
objects and they just go along
and again if you challenge that they say
you're doing semantics that's all that's
the only argument they have because they
have no way of answering all this guy
did was elude
the question
because
you can't transfer change
because change is not a physical object
not because it has anything to do with
observers
but explain to him i mean a guy has
probably a peanut brain
my god
okay uh
well says
energy is a concept
yeah
you have to reference manifestations of
the concept
reference manifestations of the concept
well i don't know how a concept can
manifest anything concept is a concept
like it says there and so you cannot
talk about manifestations meaning
actions i guess that's what he's saying
what do you mean manifestations
like moving
is that what you're saying concepts are
moving but then he says burning wood to
make heat is a transfer of energy so he
starts by saying energy is a concept and
he ends by saying transfer of energy
how do you transfer a concept period
that's the question you gotta answer
you have to identify the object i can
transfer the ball from a to b
that's called transfer in physics it's
literal
you know no no
guessing no no uh
uh
wordiness or anything it transfers
directly this is transfer transfer a
ball to from a to b that's called
transfer can you do that with energy can
you transfer energy from a to b in order
to explain that in physics not in
religion but in physics you need to make
energy appear you need to show us energy
you have to draw a picture take a
snapshot
show it on the frame on the film show me
energy before you transfer it that's the
way it works and you can't say well
that's semantic no no no no no not in
physics physics literal you got to make
the picture then you can transfer
otherwise you can't use the word
transfer but see these people talk about
transfer so much that later on they
actually believe energy is a physical
object that you can transfer
and all they're doing is an accounting
procedure
you didn't transfer money because money
is a concept you can't transfer money
even through
uh
you know through western union that's
not called transfer that's in ordinary
speech
you can't transfer concepts
you didn't transfer money through the
wire
money yeah you know you got a dollar
bill you can transfer but you that's not
what they transferred
they did an accounting procedure and
they call it transfer and people say oh
we transferred money
and these people were talking the same
way we transferred energy yeah from the
uh assets to the liabilities
you transferred energy
so what did you do did you transfer
energy through the wire did you turn
this smoke into something solid i mean
what did you do show me the picture show
me the things don't talk don't give me
an equation
show me the movie of something there
called energy that transformed from i
don't know
potential to kinetic or chemical to
kinetic
then you can talk about transfer of
energy otherwise it's just an accounting
procedure that has no meaning whatsoever
in physics
with that i'll see you next time
hopefully on sunday
uh
i'll probably be traveling this weekend
so uh i don't know if i'll see you